[MUSIC PLAYING]
So this example has
some serious effects
for production sized
apps, where you
have authentication or things
that testing should not
be confirming.
One of the difficulties
when doing production size
apps and you're running
it through unit tests
is interacting with
outside sources.
This can be authentication.
This can be database requests.
And one of the things
that we recommend you do
is you listen to a
flag or a global option
of shiny.testmode.
And if shiny.testmode
is true, I recommend
having a different UI,
or server, or reactive
behavior given this flag.
And you can have things
like the authentication
isn't even addressed.
If I do a restricted database
call, maybe instead I
load a CSV of information.
One, we're not
testing the database.
We're actually just
testing the Shiny app.
So we need to try to isolate
our test to what we can control.
And using this flag, we can
turn that behavior on or turn it
off.
And I think it's just really
great as how you can override
your apps' default behavior.
So let's look at
the app that we've
been doing in the past two
videos where we ask our name,
and it'll tell us
the first part,
or first letter of our name.
And then let's just add in
a third field of penguins.
And so to lighten the
mood a little bit,
we're going to say
how many penguins are
going to be coming for dinner.
And so let's just add
this into our app.
And we have it here.
I'm just going to run it
for demonstration purposes.
And I click Greet.
It said, Hello Barret.
The first letter
in your name is b.
And there are 333 penguins
coming for dinner.
And this is fun.
But if I keep
hitting Greet, if we
look as to where this
penguin count is coming from,
it's coming from this
authenticated database
request, or something
that I'm going
to have returned random data.
And so if I click Greet
again, now it's 330, 324, 336.
This is not
deterministic at all.
And this is, therefore,
not useful for testing.
Because if you keep running
this test over and over,
it will fail.
There will be no way
for it to be correct,
because the data
changes underneath.
So instead, we can
listen to our flag.
So I'm going to change,
just wrap this one part
and say if we'll get an
option of shiny.testmode,
we'll default this
value to false.
But if it's true, then I want to
return a test database request.
So this is something
that returns static data,
and will only retrieve
what I want it to have.
Otherwise, if I'm
not in test mode,
then let's just do the
authenticated database request.
This will be stored
into penguin data,
and then the penguin data
will count the number of rows,
and then hopefully we
have a consistent count.
Now, if I just run my
app and reload app,
this is not in testing mode.
So we should still see
our original behavior.
So I see Barret.
We see Greet.
It's something like 333, or 321,
different amount of each time
when I click Greet.
But let's run this just looking
at our application here.
So if I run this with the
app, and I call app$view,
so that I have it, it opens up
into chromium based browser,
and I have What's your name.
We call set input to Barret.
We call app Greet.
We can see that updated.
And here it says, Hello Barret.
The first letter your name is b.
And there are 68 penguins
coming for dinner.
It's a funny
phrase, but it's 68.
It's not 300.
And so if I click Greet
again, and again, and again,
and again, 68 is now constant.
And it's still
going to stay there.
If I look at the values to see
what we have, app$get_values,
I have output penguins,
there are 38 penguins coming
for dinner.
I could actually
update that, so that we
have another exported test
value of the penguin count.
So if I update with
the penguin count,
say penguin_count = a
reactive expression,
where I export
that penguin count.
Save it, and then I'm going
to stop this app here.
And then I'm just
going to restart
those interactive tests, where
I run app, and I click Greet.
And let's view it.
Now, I don't need to
necessarily open up
the viewer at the beginning.
It's usually useful
when debugging errors.
But it's still says 68.
And app$get_value of export
= penguin_count is 68.
Perfect.
So now we can make
assertions on this value,
and it'll be consistent
every single time.
This is just so useful for
getting around those database
calls that take 5, 10
minutes to execute,
or you're asking a different
API about something that is
outside the control of Shiny.
We want these unit tests
to be consistent and fast.
That way you want to do them,
and you want to do them often.
[MUSIC PLAYING]